cómo
por favor
cómo quitar el estereotipo millennial y
hacer lo que lo que te apasiona
dedicarte a lo que te apasiona cuando me
dijeron que hablara de eso lo primero
que pensé fue genial yo no sabía que yo
era millennial porque a mi edad sueño a
las 7 de la noche
y si me invitan al cine a las ocho y
media de la noche digo pero porque nos
vamos a desvelar tanto
cuál es la necesidad
entonces me puse a jugar que si era
millennial o no y después de 4 horas de
que vi vídeos de animales y de cosas en
internet todo mundo conoce los hoyos de
internet estuve 4 horas ahí me di cuenta
que si soy millennial versión en la
rayita porque los miles empiezan en 1981
más o menos y yo soy del 81 entonces ahí
estoy más o menos pero yo todavía tengo
que dejar de tomar agua a las 7 de la
noche para no levantar para servir
yo ya no voy a antros yo pensé que
ustedes eran los millennials que no les
donan las crudas cuatro días o sea
ya que acepte que soy millennial dije ok
voy a hablar de eso cada que me invitan
a hablar de cómo vivir de lo que te
apasiona me preocupo cada vez más porque
ese término vivir de lo que te apasiona
se está volviendo cada vez más peligroso
porque aparentemente ya tomo no piensa
que vive lo que te apasiona es vivir de
algo que te encanta que todo el tiempo
estás feliz que que requiere de sí de
trabajo pero es muy divertido hacerlo y
se va a resolver toda tu vida en el
momento que sepas que te apasiona ya
esto te dediques y no es cierto mentira
dejen de buscar su pasión como si fuera
un elixir mágico que les va a resolver
absolutamente todo de lo que vas a hacer
súper felices cuando se dediquen a eso
porque eso no existe
y lo descubrí dedicándome a lo que me
apasiona y dando pláticas de lo que me
apasiona
porque cada vez que me invitan a dar
este tipo de pláticas siempre las hago
claro como desde un lado super egoísta
porque hablo de mi carrera y hablo pues
para para extrañas cosas para el público
en general en realidad no me siento muy
responsable de lo que digo o sea sí
pero me voy a ir no me voy a enterar si
si les ayude si no les ayude o no no es
una responsabilidad muy grande para mí
porque pues no ver a mi casa y ya no me
entrever nada pero hace un año más o
menos me cambió la vida porque me
embaracé a propósito
[Música]
y tengo una bebé de 2 meses ya se ve
increíble
no sin ti flar 2019
este
pero una bebé de 2 meses
me puse a pensar que un día ella me va a
hacer preguntas y ahora si tengo una
responsabilidad y ahora sí voy a ver los
resultados de mis respuestas y ahora sí
tengo que pensar o sea no que no haya
pensado bien lo que vivir hoy pero ahora
sí lo tengo que pensar tres veces porque
es alguien que es parte de mí
pues un día me va a preguntar cualquier
tipo de preguntas desde de donde vienen
los bebés quién es mi papá hasta
no es cierto si sabemos
hasta como me voy a dedicar a los
apasiona cómo puedo vivir de lo que me
apasiona
entonces hoy decidí que les les va a
contestar esa pregunta cómo se la
contestaría a mi hija para practicar
y me dicen si la [ __ ] loyal a cambio
[Risas]
no importa
soy de aquí y aquí estuviera que esté
bien
sí
[Música]
estudié la carrera del hacer
comunicación
todos aquí son en verdad muy bien
entonces
les voy a contestar como le contestaría
a mi hija cómo puedes vivir de lo que te
apasiona
lo más importante para hacer lo que te
apasiona es conocerte a ti
suena como el libro de autoayuda
pero es real
y suena muy básico también hay uno está
hablando de conocerte como cuando tengo
hambre me pongo en malas no no
conocerte bien usarlo [ __ ] y los
chingón de ti que te dan miedo que te da
hueva que te frustra como como eres
cuando estás enojado como eres cuando
fracasas como eres cuando cuando te
enfrentas a diferentes cosas en tu vida
porque solo así te conoces la única
manera de conocerte es poner atención no
buscar atención y el problema de hoy en
día es que es muy difícil no buscar
atención
porque estamos viviendo ya de los likes
de los retweets de todas las cosas hacia
afuera
ya no nos conocemos porque todo estamos
viendo hacia fuera y no hacia adentro y
es imposible conocerte si vives hacia
afuera
entonces la única manera realmente de
decidir qué vas a hacer es exponerte a
vivir cosas que te van a hacer conocerte
y estoy hablando de la aprobación que
buscamos todos en general normas en
redes sociales sea como tú buscas
aprobación es la manera más fácil de no
conocer te tomar malas decisiones querer
aprobación
entonces yo estoy hablando de aprobación
de tus papás aprobación de la gente más
cercana aprobación de la gente con la
que trabajas con la gente con la que
estudio de tus amigos o sea de esa
persona que no es artista porque en su
casa le dijeron que si va muy de hambre
la persona que no anda con alguien
porque es de otra religión no tiene
muchos tatuajes y que va del cinema
de la persona que no deja una relación
porque va a estar sola y que uso de la
persona que no se va a vivir con su
pareja porque que van a decir porque en
mi casa eso no se hace ese tipo de
aprobación es la aprobación más
peligrosa y después la de afuera
y lo que más te limita como persona es
esa aprobación y se lo está diciendo una
persona que vive de la aprobación yo
vivo de los aplausos y yo vivo de las
risas y yo vivo de que a la gente le
guste mi trabajo
pero eso sólo sucede porque yo he sido
fiel a quien soy porque primero me tiene
que gustar a mí
para entonces demostrar sobre los demás
y ponerlo allá afuera y si no les gustó
pues mi perro
pero me gustan bien pero estoy orgullosa
y yo de hacerlo porque el momento que yo
renuncié yo estuve siete años en
publicidad noto que renuncie lo primero
que me prometí a mí misma es no voy a
hacer nada que no me guste a mí que no
vería yo
y es que no me gustaron y que no vería
pero consciente que la estoy haciendo
para experimentar y a ver si sí o si no
es hoy soy muy honesta en sí me gustó me
gustó conmigo
pero sólo conociendo me así entonces
puedo empezar a tomar decisiones porque
la única forma que me conocí fue
empezando a hacer las cosas por mí
a pesar de que todo el mundo me decía
que no lo hicieran cuando me creó el ver
comediante no me decía que no lo hiciera
que estaba loca que ahora quién se va a
casar contigo cosa real que me dijo mi
mamá
es 100% real
y entonces a partir de ahí y hasta hoy
he hecho y tomado decisiones que son muy
poco populares en muchos lugares
afortunadamente
porque me vale
a morir y volteo de si es que no hice
nada porque no se va a enojar
no me van a criticar nos vayan a gustar
y mi hija un día se voltea conmigo misma
cómo le hago para dedicarme y vivir de
lo que me apasiona primero lo voy a
decir endereza t no te toques ahí
en eso
es que esta prima muy serio
necesitábamos un poco
ya no puedo ser una persona normal
perdón
pero el día que mi hija me preguntó mamá
cómo le hago para hacer lo que me
apasiona como como lo hiciste tú para
dedicarte a lo que te apasiona debo
decir lo primero que tienes que hacer es
nunca hacer algo para hacerme feliz a mí
nunca nunca dejar de hacer algo para que
alguien más te quiera para que alguien
no te deje para que alguien te acepte
para que no se van a enojar tus papás
para que no te vas a quedar sin cierta
amistad para que no se vaya ir tu pareja
nunca dejes de hacer algo por alguien
más yo está hablando de cosas realmente
fuertes no vean a webber al cine con esa
persona no voy a ir porque eres lo que
no quiero hacer entonces no
estoy hablando de la esencia es decir
eso a mi hija nunca dejes de hacer nada
por mí
y si ya viviste suficiente para
conocerte
cuando la cagas quién eres cuando la
cagas quién es cuando te frustras quién
eres en todos los aspectos de tu vida
entonces vas a saber qué quieres y
cuando sepas que quieres y decidas ir
por ese camino
entonces aguanta vara porque se pone muy
cabrón
porque nunca vas a trabajar más fuerte
como cuando emprende es algo
nunca vas a dudar más de ti como cuando
estés en ese camino nunca va a estar más
cansada
nunca vas a estar más sola a veces
pero como decías estar ahí
todo se va a empezar a acomodar y si
chance no vas a tener todo el dinero que
quieres al principio y si vas a cambiar
muchas cosas y te vas a empezar a
conocer de otras maneras pero lo bueno
de todo esto es que vas evolucionando
nunca perdiendo tu esencia y si sabes
cuál es tu esencia entonces vas a saber
qué hacer
y si no sabes cuál es no pasa nada sigue
porque ahorita todo tiene una prisa por
saber qué quieres saber qué hacer y ser
exitoso rápido
que creo que es el estereotipo de los
millennials
éxito rápido aprobación rápida
ser popular rápido todo rápido y nada
pasa rápido 6.37 que no parece alce
y nada de lo que hice paso rápido y nada
de lo que hice pasó fácil y todo lo que
hice valió la pena
entonces ese es mi consejo para mi hija
y ese es mi consejo para ustedes
conozcan se primero y después tomen
decisiones
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]